TV fans are remembering actress  Charlotte Rae best known for her role as  mrs. Garrett in the popular sitcom the  facts of life she died yesterday at the  age of 92 I had to learn that loving  someone doesn't mean just loving the  parts you like loving means accepting  the whole package this was so sad guys  the Tony and Emmy nominated actress  starred as the wise and patient  character for nearly a decade of course  the facts of life was a spinoff from  Diff'rent Strokes in which Rae played  the same character last year Rae  revealed she'd been diagnosed with bone  cancer I grew up watching my cards and  if I take the good you take the bad take  them both and there you have the four  back of let go that's all I know from  the song oh come on  [Laughter]